hello everyone and welcome back to San
Martin theater in Buenos Aires it's the
finals of the 1971 candidates Tigran
worth on which petrosyan versus Bobby
Fischer now as you've seen in Game one
pettersson played a really creative game
with the black pieces he completely
chose a different style than the one he
usually chooses I didn't go into some
passive defensive mode where he you know
simply tries to outlast his opponent but
rather he went on an all-out attack
against Bobby Fischer Fischer defended
and in the end the petrosyan was unable
to reach move 42 you know gain more time
to reach time control he blundered and
then he resigned before even reaching a
time control so game 1 against the boat
Larsen in tomorrow were very feisty
games in the end Fischer game on top and
such was the case in this match versus
Petrosyan but now Fischer has the black
pieces and he has the face now
patrolling with the white white pieces
obviously now for some reason Fischer
was late for this game well not much
some three minutes but still you don't
want to be late to such an important
game and it's very interesting how this
whole game turned out some officials
other opponents after losing the game
day you know would change their styles
and you know they didn't really want to
repeat known opening lines and go a lot
into theory against Fischer but here we
have a completely different case
so after losing the game this is now how
petrosyan treats the you know the
situation so let's check it out we don't
have a nice photo of the match it's not
from this game since Fischer has a
knight f6 & e6 on the board and well in
this game there will be a knight of 6 in
g6 on the board but still a very nice
photo you know just to get in the mood
so let's check it out Petrosyan has the
white pieces and he opens with d4 Knight
to f6 by Fischer c4 and the g6 so the
Kings Indian defense is on the board
Knight to c3 and now we have d5
transposing it to the groom fell defense
Bishop to F for the Brinkmann attack and
now Bishop to g7 here we have III and
here there is a known game between
Petros and unfortunately which Petrosyan
won in 1961 so 10 years before the
game was played where fortunately I
continued by by castling but here
Fischer chooses a different path he goes
c5 and okay it's a somewhat over less
known line but Fischer will try to make
it work well you'll see how it will turn
out we have D captures on c5 now Queen
to a5 pinning the knight on c3 I would
have looked a c1 and now Knight to e4
here a Fischer creates a triple attack
against the c3 Knight with the knight
Bishop and the Queen and petrosyan
simply plays C captures on d5 which is
the strongest reply now of course you
cannot capture with the bishop here if
you play Bishop captures on c3 with
check you get B captures and now if you
capture with the knight then you get
Queen to d2 and you lose a piece here
you can't move the knight you can't
defend it and the Queen is undefended on
a5 so you would lose a piece here and
the game on the other hand after this B
captors on c3 if you play Knight
captures on c5 simply Bishop to h6 is
enough for white because black has so
many dogs who are weaknesses and he
doesn't have a dark square Bishop even
though the material on the board is
equal white would have a much much much
better game probably probably enough
enough to win
so after C captures on d5 we have Knight
captures on c3 by Fischer and now of
course you cannot capture if eb captures
then Bishop captures on c3 you have to
move the King and now of course the
black is better here
so after Knight captures on c3 the only
response from Petrosyan is Queen to d2
and this is the strongest reply now the
knight is pinned and you will only then
recapture the piece since you can't move
the knight the Queen is once again
undefended on a5 Queen captures on a to
Fischer grabs upon we have B captures on
c3 and now although you can capture the
Queen here Queen capture screen captures
you don't want to go into this okay you
do have a past a pawn but for example
after c4 and d4 Petrosyan will have a
massive central pawn structure and the
white will be better here so after B
captures on c3 we have Queen back to a5
by Fischer now comes Bishop to c4 and
here a Fisher doesn't recapture material
immediately there's plenty of time for
that first he developed
we have 92 d7 and now comes Knight to e2
and okay Knight to e5 Fischer goes after
petrosian's LightSquared Bishop Ussher
back to a2 and now Bishop to a5 Fischer
still continues developing pieces
there's always time to recapture pawns
Bishop captures on e5 Bishop captures on
e5 and the now comes Knights the d4 and
okay Fischer now recaptures the pawn
Queen captures on c5 we have nine
characters on f5g captures an f5 and
here patrols and simply castles he's not
afraid of the semi open G file Fischer
has but Fischer has some problems here
he can't really Castle kingside and of
course castling queenside is no better
as both Queen side and Kings side are
pretty much wide open so he has a king
stuck in the center he has a double deaf
pawn and it will be very hard to deal
with all of this
so okay he goes Queen back to 85 what do
you do here but there are some places
Queen to c2 he he um pins so now he can
push c4 and also he's attacking the f5
pawn pressure pushes f4 and here
Petrosyan finds a very nice idea he
pushes c4 we have F captures and III by
Fischer and a now petrosyan pushes c5
again creating a very nice pawn chain
well a nice C and D pawn in the center
as you can see these pawns are now
controlling all of these squares and he
doesn't mind about for example he
khafre's on f2 simply Queen captures now
your f7 pawn is under attack and every
push f6 d6 will bust open the center and
white will White will break through
so after c5 we have Queen to d2 Fischer
offers offers the Queen trade and this
would be this would be okay for white so
Petros and of course declines it he goes
Queen to f4 this comes with check and
now you can't really go to d8 this would
be you know a bit too much asking for
trouble after rook to d1 attacking the
Queen for example Queen e2 now comes the
d6 and even a pawn captures on f2 check
is not a problem because rook captures
and the Queen is guarding the rook on d1
so here whatever you play white will
simply break through and it's it's all
over so after Queen to a for King to f8
by Fischer we have Roxy
attacking the Queen and now we have
Queen to e2 by Fisher and now comes v6 a
Petrosyan is now threatening to break
through the threat is of course D
captors on a7 would check but also this
opens up this very strong bishops
diagonal so here if Fisher is not
careful for example if he pushes East
six then you get Queen to h4 with a lot
of with a lot of ideas here for example
Queen can come to e7 and whatever you do
for example if you try to develop the
rook good ideas that if Queen comes then
King can escape then even Bishop
captures an e6 will be an idea now of
course you cannot capture because of
Queen to e7 checkmate so a very
unpleasant position for Fischer he tries
Queen to h5 and this is the correct idea
you can't allow Queen to come to h4
petrosyan now as Fischer is threatening
checkmate on h2 petrosyan has to deal
with this and he finds a very
interesting way of dealing with it he
pushes f4 which prevents checkmate but
it allows this pawn to e to move a nice
exchange sacrificed by Petrosyan which
allows him to continue his initiative so
KF captures an e5 we have a capture some
d1 with check of course Fischer brings
another Queen into the game rook
captures on d5 and e1 and now comes
Queen captures on e5 and here okay you
could continue with something like D
captures only seven but the black black
could actually perhaps hold this after
Queen captures let's say rook to f1 you
threaten f7 black can simply continue
developing and if you give up the Queen
here for some remaining pieces still
Fischer would have two rooks against the
Queen and Petrosyan would really have to
you know work who work really hard to to
create some winning chances here so okay
after Queen to e5 Petrosyan finds it the
best move which is root 2 f1 immediately
threatening on f7 f6 displayed and now
comes Queen to b3 first here with the
threat of checkmate on f7 you have to
prevent this trying to prevent this by
giving up some material with e6 doesn't
work in terms of Queen captures on b7
threatening the rook also Queen can come
to e7 so after rook to e8 you get c6 and
now you can see that the
they're simply too powerful if Queen
captures then of course rook captures
and if six will lead the checkmate after
Queen Queen to f7 okay Queen to b3
threatening checkmate King to g7 is
played Fischer tries to run away with
the King Queen to f7 check we have King
to h6 and now comes the strongest move
the only good move in the position D
captures me7 now removing the defender
of the f6 pawn and now rook captures on
f6 is a terrible threat Fischer pushes
f5 but it doesn't really help him
Petrosyan place the rook captures on f5
we have Queen to d4 check and here and
move 32 after Petrosyan played King to
h1 Fischer resigned the game so there we
have it it's been since since Palma de
Majorca last year well in 1970 so 10
months almost 10 months have passed
since Fischer last lost his game to bent
Larsen in palma de mallorca inter-zonal
and here we have after 20 consecutive
victories Tigran Petrosian manages to
break Fischer's winning streak and now
win the game with the white pieces so it
said that's some of the one thing Isaac
Kirsten said about this event he said
that it's not a Fischer's winning streak
it's it's not only over it smashed to
smithereens that's the meaning of the
quote above the board and also it is
said that the crowd of 1200 people
inside the san martin theater in Buenos
Aires and also 2,000 people outside
outside in the lobby chanted Steiger and
Tigran which is why that is the title of
this video so yeah a beautiful game by
Ticknor Petrosyan where you know he
faces a last known line of the groom
field but you know he creates a
masterpiece and wins this very nice game
against Bobby Fischer he officially
resigned of course because now there's
really nothing to do after after one
check white will simply block and after
you go back let's say queen g4 rope to
f6 is coming and now you're simply
getting checkmated
for example Queen here King goes back
rook h6 Queen has the block and now
Queen to g3 will be checkmate
so here you can see that
he did win his match against the time
out of six to zero and also his match
against Larsen six to zero you can see
that Tigran Petrosian is very much a
different kind of opponent
so even though petrosyan lost Game one
he didn't you know bow down to Fisher
and his amazing glory and and all of his
legend but rather he stood up to him and
played this beautiful masterpiece and
and want his game so now the match
simply continues so there you have it
a beautiful masterpiece by Tigran
Petrosian I do hope you enjoyed it and
that you're enjoying the Bobby Fischer
series so far I would like to thank drew
jaguar scott zonin born nikola dedushka
julian popov and christopher fernandez
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check too on my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon our most likely
with game number three of Fisher
petrosyan but also I will try to check
some of your suggestions and maybe we'll
have you know something to break the
series before game 3 thank you all and
I'll see you soon